[Musique]
bonsoir les amis bonsoir les amis avez
vous été sage aujourd'hui
avez vous été sage aujourd'hui et mehdi
d'angres aux ours
tu as fini de répéter toutes mes paroles
comme un perroquet comme un perroquet ou
au pardon patron je pense grosos a
apporté un jeu de cartes pour faire une
partie avec petit douillet mirabel on va
jouer au bridge patron ou à la belote
c'est une excellente idée et ils
aideront beaucoup ça j'en ai bien la
pression mais tu ne dois pas tricher
nounours compris vous fois son patron je
ne triche jamais vous le savez bien
enfin on verra à feu au au vote lors il
ne triche pas nous reportons pomme pas
mon propos on propose non pas pour
autant on peut entrer enfin recevoir les
enfants joly dites moi
avez vous été sages comme des images
bon et bien on va jouer ensemble moteur
aux gendarmes et aux volets dont les
enfants pas de ces jeux barba on va
jouer aux cartes on va jouer au bridge
au bridge comme ta maman au nom alors je
te jure pour les oui bon et bien on va
jouer à la belote pour nous on pourrait
peut-être j'ai pas moins faire un rami
ou incana spa alors que diriez-vous
d'une petite partie de battage une idée
oui d'accord mais bon moi c'est moi tu
m'étonnes
mais qu'est ce que tu fais nounours
tiens quelqu'un qui triche gros yeux
revoit nouveau ne regarde pas mes cartes
là là ça y est à toi tu commencé petit
louis
10 rouge danois j'ai des chiens aboient
à moi en place de piquets serrés moitié
gagné chez target bien moi non
alors je continue 2 cette fois tu vas
perdre bataille
on a ce talent voilà je me rappelle
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai c'est toi
qui as triché petit louis oui mais c'est
marie gasnier bande de tricheurs
voilà patron jarry lui patron c'est moi
qui ai commencé à tricher
allons on lit les enfants une autre fois
on jouera au bridge c'est un jeu
beaucoup plus
tu trouveras plus à nos moeurs c'est
promis les enfants je ne tricherai plus
là j'éteins la lumière à demain les
enfants
ulysse va me passionne c'est ce avons
rencontré chef d'un émirat mal d'amis
qui lui
[Musique]
la ville un de tricher au jeu je ne suis
pas content du tout grosse jours ça a
été très vilain à vous voilà monsieur le
tricheur
vous pouvez être fiers de vous c'est du
propre
je ne le ferai plus pas trop je vous le
promets pour de punir
tu ne mangeras pas de miel demain ni
après-demain bien pop ont beau nul et
enfin embrasser vite vos parents est
allé sagement vous coucher demain je
vous raconterai une belle histoire
bonne nuit bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh